I'm a big proponent of meditation and mindfulness and just trying to,
and it's sad.
That's all those are toxic words right now.
Meditation and mindfulness.
Yeah.
I've been thrown around by too many knuckleheads.
Like there's something about it that it's like,
oh,
that's kind of a bull shitty word.
You kind of,
you know what I mean?
You're like,
oh,
I'm just all about mindfulness.
Like,
oh,
you're annoying.
That's what you are,
dude.
You're the annoying guy.
I,
I saw a book just yesterday and one of these like boutique stores,
someone had made it star cast at kids,
but called the grownups guide to mindfulness and whoever wrote that fucking book
hates the word mindful.
Hey,
this is definitely has an obnoxious friend who's into mindfulness because of the
book is just like a,
first of all,
they,
the guy doesn't seem to really understand what it is in the book.
Like it's a,
he seems a little confused about the nature of it,
but,
uh,
and I remember looking at that and be like,
oh,
I guess people are getting annoyed with the word mindfulness now.
Like the pendulum swinging that way.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's one of those words that people love to say it sounds good and it makes you
seem like a,
like a spiritual person.
So again,
when work gets moved around and used too much,
like something happens to it where it gets icky.
Yeah.
Cause it's like it becomes popular and then people start using it and then you
see like a bunch of phony guru type dudes at seminars using it.
What's important here is mindfulness.
Very important that,
you know,
there's like typically unique behaviors.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's,
especially when it comes to like,
people are full of Shit.
I was like a typical uniqueness.
Like there's a just a thing that a lot of people adopt and it sounds like
everyone else and it's just a way that people get wet.
And uh,
I,
I hope you understand like what are you doing?
Why are you doing that?
You,
you're adopting this weird,
funky thing.
And you know,
I think it's really important that we practice mindfulness.
It falls into that.
It falls into that even though it's an excellent practice.
Well,
it's very important,
but people,
you know,
it's called an,
um,
I just,
and now I took on,
for lack of better word,
I'm working with a actual teacher of the you lineage of Buddhism,
which is like choke him,
is lineage of Buddhism and he's amazing and he's,
and he's teaching me mindfulness meditation practice,
this Guy David Nichtern.
But um,
how does he deal with masturbation?
What's cool about him is if you asked him,
he'd,
he would tell you.
I'm sure he,
there's no like,
yeah.
With,
you know,
that he wouldn't be like,
well,
how dare you ask me that question.
But I think that probably I don't,
I can't answer for him.
I think of a phone line with what you're saying with balance,
you know,
which is that,
it's really like,
uh,
sort of the,
the,
the concept with it is the thing that is happening right now,
whatever it may be,
you can just,
you know,
apply mindfulness.
It,
you could apply like a being in the moment and being with the thing that's
happening right now.
And so the,
the thing that he's teaching me,
I love it so much dude.
Because it isn't,
we will we or like out there crazy.
It's literally this very simple way that you meditate,
the way that you sit,
which is you sit on a cushion,
you put your hands on your knees in and you sit back and that he,
the word they use in this Cargill,
in each Ford is the warrior pose.
And what that means is that it's a kind of confidence.
It's the way like people who are like confident sit.
So you sit like that when you're meditating,
you're legs across and you sit in a chair if you want and you look straight
ahead about eight feet,
nine feet,
and you watch your breath and when you're going to your thoughts,
which happens of course you go,
you think thinking and then you go back to your breath.
That's it.
You say thinking,
you don't say it,
you think it.
Thank.
Thank you.
Thinking just so cause what,
what's all these,
so like what,
what you start realizing when you start this practice and full disclosure here,
man,
you know me Joe,
I have problems with discipline and I have problems with like sticking to stuff
over and over again and working with this guy has been incredible because it's
actually getting me to,
to do it right?
Uh,
but still I have like,
I did it today,
didn't do it yesterday.
I'm just,
I don't want to get out there and some nonsense that I'm like spending all day
long meditation.
But what you start seeing is when you're doing it is you realize like,
oh,
there's a cycle happening in my consciousness.
In my mind.
There's a cycle that's happening in my life,
which is that I kind of blink into the moment following the breath and I blink
out of the moment into the thought realm,
right?
We're like little fireflies wee flicker into the moment where here now we're
here.
We're not lost in our thoughts.
We're not thinking about the next thing we're going to say.
We're not thinking about the next thing we're going to do.
We're just here in this moment and then we're off,
you know,
often running,
like thinking about the bills,
figured about the girl,
thinking about the thing.
They get about that.
And then that leads to another thought and another thought.
Next thing you know you've been thinking for three years straight,
you know what I mean?
Or three minutes or five hours or whatever,
and then you come back and that's the cycle.
This is a cycle that happens.
So mindfulness is starting to pay attention and,
and,
and to that cycle.
And,
and the breathing thing is kind of like a respiratory mnemonic device,
which is that suddenly what's been happening to me now is I'll just be like
walking down the street and then notice my breath.
Oh Shit,
I'm back.
Oh,
I'm
here.
I was totally over in my head.
Oh,
I'm back.
That was thinking,
you know,
that's all.
It's very,
very,
very simple.
But he's just teaching me the basic shit right now.
It does.
I think it pretty interesting on my own thinking about my own life and observing
other people's lives.
I've come up with this thing that I bring up all the time.
The momentum of your past,
like your,
your like so many people as they're going down the street.
So many people as they're interacting with people,
they're carrying the momentum of all the fucked up things that are going on,
bills that they have to pay and things that they forgot to do and a career they
never chase.
And a girl they never called back.
And the thing that they lied about and the thing they stall and the reason why
they got fired from work.
And maybe if I call my boss and all this craziness you're bringing with you into
everything that is so hard to escape.
It's so hard for people to escape the momentum of the past.
You know,
people sort of a,
they get into this thing of defining themselves by failures,
by past failures.
And it never just learning from them go,
oh,
I'm that fucking loser.
You know,
it's a real problem.
It's a real problem with people to be able to learn from something and to just
look at yourself.
And it's painful to look at yourself.
So everybody wants to pretend that they didn't do anything wrong right there.
Everybody else is an asshole and that,
yeah,
and so you,
when you're doing what you're doing by doing that is you're stunting your own
growth.
You feel like you're protecting yourself because you protecting your ego.
You're like,
you know,
I didn't do anything wrong.
Fuck him.
He is the asshole.
But you know,
you could've avoided that.
You know,
you could've done better.
Like everybody has moments like that and their life.
The more you avoid those and don't take credit for the ones that you actually
fucked up,
the more you actually hurt yourself in this ironic thing because it seems like
you're protecting yourself.
Know your ECOMM exonerating myself from guilt this,
fuck it.
It wasn't me.
I wouldn't do it.
But you know,
you did.
So in your head,
you're the guy who lies about making mistakes instead of you're the guy who mans
up to your mistakes and realizes it was a mistake.
And then vows to do better.
Yeah,
man,
that's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
You have to just have to be able to say you're wrong.
You have to be able to say,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
you have to be able to,
and you gotta be able to look at yourself like all the time,
not even just when you fuck up because you can avoid some of those fuck ups.
Just look at yourself critically along the way.
But we all have to understand that are we are all in evolving process.
Like I had this conversation with Dennis Mckenna.
It's a crazy conversation because it's a ridiculous thing to say.
And he was talking about Donald Trump and I was saying d isn't it possible that
he could grow and learn?
Like why do we give up on people?
Why does a guy get to a certain age?
And we say,
oh,
he's 60 he set in his ways.
He's 70 he'll never change.
He'll never evolve.
You don't ever say that about a 20 year old.
You see some asshole who's a 20 year old.
He say he just needs discipline and just needs love,
finds the right PR people in his life,
right person until to love.
He'll be okay.
He's going to mature and eventually it's going to be a solid man.
But you get to a certain age we just give up on you.
Yeah.
We just like,
you're still alive,
but you've passed the cycle that I usually enjoy people to be ready to like sort
of interact as valuable,
creative,
loving members of society and pass that by.
You're still thinking about yourself.
Only deepen your sixties this is stupid shit.
This is shit he's supposed to do when you're 17 by the time you're 70 you're
supposed to be going,
oh my God,
I don't have much time left.
Oh my God.
What have I done while I've here?
What do,
what is important?
What do I feel the best about?
I feel the best about love and companionship and friendship and real warmth and
interaction between people that you care about.
This money thing,
man,
this is not,
it can't keep chasing this.
Can't keep chasing power.
Can't keep chasing money.
It's,
you're gunna reach a point where it's not going to matter because you're going
to die.
So you really want to be that guy from the bumper sticker.
He who dies with the most toys wins because this is literally what you're
working towards.
You're working towards a joke.